[Music]
what's prepping for a night out what is
that this video is killing me he
drenched in Cologne LMFAO
first one cologne
dude that's he's flammable at this point
at least on the head on the head top of
the head is crazy
because when I go down on your [ __ ]
she's going to want to smell this [ __ ]
that's crazy
oh dude dude he's gonna draw Jeremy
fragrance out of a [ __ ] air glider
bro
I smell you air drops in I smell you
smell
[Laughter]
going
it's a good question where the [ __ ] is
he going dude he knows three you know
he's like
he's going somewhere where everyone has
coveted yeah you know yep
it's layering too he's layering imagine
he this is a multi-layered scent imagine
he if for those on audio this this man
is literally like
drenching himself in Cologne
what if he just works at the local like
like Waste Management yeah because I'm
tired of it it smells like [ __ ] in there
I can't not another day okay too
he leaned back for that one today
who taught this man and how to apply
this
[Applause]
on the clothes
another day you smelling good
[Music]
Tick Tock introduced their PornHub sound
yeah seriously I hate it
but [ __ ] you with that imagine this guy
walking by you
[Laughter]
like the air would like noticeably
change viscosity ionizes dude yeah yeah
people having cruising cruising down the
street
God damn that's all Magneto is just to
do with too much perfume on
just just juggling marbles in his left
hand all these people falling over as he
walks on just like
[Laughter]
how far do you think he smells oh that's
a good question what's his rate what's
like the radius of his smell
you think in open air I think I think
you still have to be decently close I
think 10 feet like I think cash in a
closed room smell that yeah yeah no in a
room like this 10 feet oh he's opening
your are you saying yeah it's like on
the street I think you still have to go
past them yeah yeah but yeah I think in
a room easily 10 feet dude imagine going
like that he's going to the doctor's
office
this is a small Medical Building
yeah
yeah yep opens the door and just like
smoke yeah
hot boxes around
I'm picturing him in the lobby and it's
like an old ass medical building and the
person sitting in there is competing
with the smell of the old ass building
yeah and the 25 cents he has on it just
[Music]
brain hurting ow [ __ ] it do you think he
lives in an apartment did he get in an
elevator sharing an elevator I was just
about to say that
just last second it's closing you're
like oh can I just sting and the doors
keep your arm and it opens
[Laughter]
yes dude yes
I brought this up right yeah yeah
wait what is this
dude you never seen this thing so is
that real dude yeah dude look this up
dude you
hey I'm just saying I said it the
[ __ ] is flammable dude
foreign
[Laughter]
so what's the move
wait what what is that dude YouTube
search
like what is he lighting guidelights
firework
that is the biggest explosion
you don't understand being casual
laughing at this for like a week
straight how did his body like move no
bro you need to see the original please
search it oh my God
Luke can you search it
I remember I scrubbed through these
frames and it's like on frame three he's
still just like this but it's all fire
I mean is he okay that he died yeah no
he lives okay yeah he lives he's like
third degree burns his body but I think
like it happens and he just like walks
away but how does his body go from over
here to like shifting with you over here
because I think that's the person
throwing freaking the [ __ ] out you're
like oh
foreign
yeah
yeah yeah how is he fine
bro bro
no Play it Again Play Again play again
[Music]
first of all this sound the sound of the
okay and then here
[Laughter]
he looks like Slenderman
I gotta get it the perfect moment on my
bed yeah yeah
scroll back like two frame
like the amount of frame before he
actually does anything is so [ __ ]
funny
[Laughter]
hit the [ __ ] fire
[Music]
I love it because it's not actually
Flames no it's like the fireworks
it's like beautiful but like right here
oh my god dude
it's 10 frames before he actually moves
dude that one where he's just it's all
right
[Laughter]
he's just standing in the fireman yeah
oh man
the cologne maybe you're a firework you
know maybe you're a firework for sure
dude
God now God damn